so so the show's over that I'm dying up
here so what are you doing and what do
you want I'm gonna go back but you think
get back on the road in 2019 but you
have a podcast and it's called
whiskey ginger yeah I was one of your
guest the best episode is yours it's the
first one yeah everybody loves it we
talked about it yeah we did we probably
do have 10 more times
no we that first episode we shot at
first one hour yeah and then we after
we've finished it we looked at each
other got that I will say that I knew I
loved Eric Griffin and you guys have a
good thing going yeah but should I die
my final wish is for you guys to do a
podcast together I don't think there are
two better people who me and Griffin
Bobby
Oh me and Robert Robert yeah we've
talked we have actually talked about it
many times but let me say this the
amount of fans of his that say nice
stuff to me is it's it's crazy and they
all go you guys should just do anything
together I think so I think we should do
a show together I would same kind of
relationship I would love that it's
racist no much why not we also did a
podcast a year ago where you said to me
let's do a podcast mm-hmm
we're never gonna air it release it yeah
and we can say whatever we want you know
we should still do that but we did that
already
I know I know you'll never release it
never red and yellow yeah but what red
and yellow we could combine and what
color is at orange all right yeah then
that's more me Ryan yeah we don't we
don't do that yeah but we I do have that
podcast and it will never get released
but you know what's so great when I do
die a tragic death yeah when they were
sifting through all my dog [ __ ] stand up
yeah I'm so scared of that by the way
that I have tapes of bit you know
because I've taped myself at a club and
they give me the tape and usually like
watch it down sometimes yeah I have tons
of that stuff I need to like [ __ ]
burn and get rid of it because I don't
want someone to be like posthumously
released [ __ ] raw scares me yeah it's
garbage a lot of it so garbage yeah but
like that I'm gonna hide somewhere very
sexy and make a code and a thing and go
you want to hear one of the most [ __ ]
podcasts I mean we said things that
would ruin our career yep Wow yeah like
every line was a career ruin yep that
was so freeing I mean to say everything
actually I've let three people listen to
it yeah those three people told me that
that was the one of the most fun things
I've ever heard in their life but they
were like you know you can't do anything
with that [ __ ] social yeah I think
our careers would be over I'm being
genuine they would actually because it's
sexual it's very [ __ ] anyway but you
know what it is everyone should try to
do one of those oh yeah because it's
it's free oh so nice it's great therapy
today well we're talking you and I there
are things I want to say that my gut
don't you me but I don't do it yeah but
it's like I stopped myself you know
better I know better
yeah or even things there on the fans
you know I try to stop myself is there
anybody that we know that doesn't hold
themselves back I think I'm trying to
think I don't think so
there's a podcast called calm town what
is that who is that those guys you know
about what are their names and stuff
Stavros what is it dirty to be dirty um
no I think that they're just they just
say it all and everything but not even
to be provocative I don't think that
they refuse to be to hold to practice
restraint do they say the N word and
[ __ ] George I've heard it holy [ __ ] yeah
yeah there's an audience hell yeah
they're killing it patriotic am i a
40,000 before yes support them to do
know that's awesome I I'm not I'm not
[ __ ] on them I don't know those guys
I think it's awesome I just I'm
surprised I'm surprised that like I'm
surprised I don't know they're the most
I don't know a lot of [ __ ] I don't but
here's the thing though it's like it
wouldn't it be a great country if we
could just say whatever we wanted well
you can I know but this thing is that
without any consequence well that's
insane you can't have anything without
contract right as this is my this is my
point about the way I talk to you and
the way we joke around yeah I'm willing
to face any kind of consequence for
anything that I say to you out of jail
that when we're joking around when
someone who said oh you're being racist
I go no I'm not
yeah I'm willing to face it because I
know the truth of it
yeah like when I would never joke around
about something that I wasn't sure at
the truth of it when everyone's gauge
and you sometimes go into an Asian
accent yes I always watch it it's my
favorite thing with you so hard to see
the audience here mean they give me back
they get tired
yeah they don't get it so now look I
look at I look at Asians in the crowd
yeah when you're doing it you hear me
cackle yeah I'm cackling in the back
like a maniac because I do it because I
don't want him also I want to protect
him yes it is sit by me laughing like a
maniac makes other people oh comedians
okay what they do in comedy or whatever
yeah I think people need to know that it
is a part of our world to joke around
with each other yeah I want the one
thing you don't do well as a comic well
I'll say this the one thing you never do
as a comedian to another comedian is
like get on stage after them and then
make fun of their material or market
right you don't go mocking someone's
material unless you're really close and
you've had a kind of a conversation
about right but you don't take shots at
someone's [ __ ] material yeah and make
a stupid comment about their [ __ ]
meant to do you know no you know it's so
funny that you say that and then uh what
you're doing what I would let the
audience in on it okay they're not gonna
say any name what am i doing but before
the podcast started I had mentioned two
comedians yeah that made fun of my
material when I brought them up they're
comics that are I still work with and I
have no problem with them wink wink
yep and listen to now on at the end we
had
[Music]